david le premier ministre refuse d'obéir
à la contestation populaire il garde son
cap
quelle est l'atmosphère l'ambiance sur
place et bien comme vous pouvez le voir
derrière moi grégory et bien une poignée
elle de manifestants continuent de
camper ici devant le parlement afin de
réclamer la démission du premier
ministre nikol pashinian hier ils
étaient plus de 5000 à se réunir devant
le parlement aujourd'hui ça devrait être
plus calme mais on s'organise en tout
cas pour maintenir un ca campement une
scène a même été monté ici est juste
devant le parlement enfin que des prises
de parole en public elle soit organisé
un important dispositif de sécurité a
été mis en place un tout autour du
parlement pour éviter à tout débordement
les forces de l'ordre entoure ces tentes
afin qu'il n'y ait pas de débordements
et d'affrontement avec les partisans pro
pashinian en tout cas s est malgré cette
nouvelle déconvenue nikol pashinian va
présenter au président arménien une
nouvelle demande de révocation la du
chef de l'état major de l'armée
arménienne le général onic agace pariant
annonces faites sur sa page facebook ce
duel à distance entre les deux hommes
intensifie un peu plus la crise
politique que traverse le pays la
tension reste palpable puisque de
nombreux citoyens continuent de
supporter le premier ministre en place
il ya d'ailleurs lancé un nouvel appel à
manifester à demain il invite ses
partisans à un nouveau rassemblement
place de la république à 18h30 heure
locale a toujours dans un message posté
sur facebook hier soir un appel qui
devrait donner lieu à des affrontements
puisque une autre mobilisation contre le
premier ministre est organisée également
à 16h ans pour contester le pouvoir en
place est parmi les partisans entier
apache ignore on retrouve pas mal
d'anciens officiels du gouvernement je
propose de les écouter
je pense qu'après les dernières réunions
très intense la décision à laquelle
id ans est parvenu est importante car
elle indique la direction dans laquelle
nous avançons avec cette décision prise
en exerçant son droit constitutionnel le
président a démontré au premier ministre
sa volonté de contrer les actes
anticonstitutionnels de ce dernier
j'espère vraiment que cette décision
signifie que nous nous orientons avec
dans cette direction en respectant la
constitution
aujourd'hui en vertu de la constitution
de la république d'arménie
le premier ministre arménien ne
représente plus un pouvoir légitime son
gouvernement non plus il existe un grand
nombre d'actes constitutionnel qui l'a
violée il a de cette manière miner la
légitimité de son pouvoir de facto la
seule entité légitime et le président de
la république
vous le savez un l'armée a lâché 1
nicolas pas xi'an la défaite ses
militaires dans le haut-karabagh face à
l'azerbaïdjan est vécu comme une
humiliation nationale pour certains à
12,7 contestation populaire qui touche
la population locale mais aussi les
anciens
l officiel ce qui faut noter également
et contrairement à ce qu'on peut voir ou
entendre en tout cas c'est le ressenti
un con qu'on a sur place
eh bien il est totalement différent
puisque les contestations sont plutôt
pacifique malgré elle c'est vrai
quelques affrontements et des tensions
en détention et qui ont donné lieu à des
images assez violente
mais globalement le soulèvement reste
relativement sous contrôle des forces de
l'ordre qui sont en nombre ici merci
david khalifa en direct donc de erevan
capitale de l'arménie